foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar real-time
whole genome sequencing surveillance for
healthcare outbreak detection and
investigation
I am Kaylee Bach of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by optgen
options portfolio includes services and
software for bacterial isolate whole
genome sequencing and opt-in is excited
to support this webinar presented by Dr
Alex Sunderman an expert in this field
to learn more visit optgen.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
Alex Sunderman assistant professor of
infectious diseases at University of
Pittsburgh Dr Sunderman welcome you may
now begin your presentation
hello good afternoon good morning
wherever you're listening in from um
thanks for that introduction uh like I
said they said my name is Alex Sunderman
uh and happy to talk to everyone here
today about some research and
application that our research group has
done on genomic sequencing surveillance
to investigate Healthcare outbreaks and
investigate them at our Hospital
so some things that I want to cover
today three primary objectives is to
talk about some of the past history of
outbreak detection and the current use
of genomic sequencing and Hospital
outbreak investigation today in
infection prevention it gives us a
really good frame of mind about how far
we've come and what the future might
hold for us second talk about a new
technology of genomic sequencing
surveillance and how that's emerging
into real-time application nowadays and
then lastly talk about some of the
barriers that we're seeing that I think
other people are seeing to actually
Implement that surveillance technique
into practice for infection prevention
so going a very long time ago back into
the 1850s looking at some of the first
uh outbreak investigations that were
well recorded we all know the the Jon
Snow of the Broad Street from cholera
outbreak um in the 1850s where there was
a large cholera outbreak happening
within the region
and there are some two competing
theories at that time of what might be
causing that outbreak the first being
miasma that there is a cholera in the
air and then the second being germ
contaminated water which was coming from
the River Thames uh Downstream that was
supplying water essentially to two
companies that was giving water to these
areas where they were seeing this
outbreak and Jon Snow famously made this
map here on the right to uh look at the
number of Cholera cases that was seen in
a certain region within a certain time
frame
um in a more modern view of that today
now would probably look like this with
this heat map where you see that Broad
Street pump located there in the Middle
with each of these cases uh air deaths
represented on the map here
showing that the majority of these cases
were located within a certain region
that was recorded within a certain time
frame
so the outcome of this essentially
traced back to this Broad Street pump
that had the color contaminated water
and again like I said his theory was
mainly based upon that there was an
observed increased incidence from an
established Baseline of Cholera
happening within the region within a
certain time frame and then looking at
some of that data they're able to show
that it was coming from that River where
the Broad Street was supplying that
water rather than the Upstream towns and
areas where that water wasn't
contaminated so I want people to focus
on this this last bullet point here is
that there's an observed increase
incidence from an established Baseline
so whenever we switch over to a
different example looking at origins of
Hospital outbreak investigation it's
important to go back to symbolize back
into the 1840s it was really credited
for the establishment of hand hygiene
within hospitals and what he was looking
at was two obstetrical clinics and this
incidence of pyrol fever within newborns
and mothers
what he noted uh was there was obviously
an observed difference between the
clinic where uh there was births
happening inside the clinic versus
bursts that were happening outside the
clinics essentially on on the street or
other areas and that the difference
between these clinics is that one of
them had midwives and the other one had
medical students where they would
actually perform these autopsies and
then hypothesize that there's a
transmission of this cadaverous
particles
but what they recorded here over a few
years again was an observed increased
incidence from this established Baseline
where they saw one Clinic had a higher
rate of this disease compared to another
um which was really important to note to
make the intervention of hand washing to
establish that
so what does this actually look like on
a timeline we have semi-wise in the
1840s we had Jon Snow and the Broad
Street pump in the 1850s where we had
this this technique of looking at
observing increase from an established
Baseline if we go ahead um toward the
more modern era
um in 2016 there was this great paper um
published by the CDC
um uh prevention epicenters program
where they looked at how do people
detect outbreaks within hospitals and
some quotes here are methods used for
outbreak detection we're
non-standardized and limited to a small
set of targeted organisms and they
relied on visual inspection of line
lists it's detect outbreaks and formally
also as well that the cluster detection
ideally would be automated use
statistical based methods to be more
accurate than what hospitals are
actually doing at this time frame and
this was a survey of 33 different
hospitals within the region and found
that nothing was really standard among
all of these so if you think about this
technique again it's still an observed
increase incidence from an established
Baseline within a certain area and time
so we go back to this chart here looking
at the 1850s up to now we're 170 years
later and we're essentially still using
the same techniques
and that's where one of my favorite
quotes come from uh with Dr Sharon
peacock
um uh said this in one of her papers
back in 2018 is the Paradigm for
Hospital outbreak detection has un been
unchanged for over 150 years we're still
using the same techniques of geotemporal
clustering looking for an increased
incidence within a certain time frame
and um this other paper that used some
sequencing surveillance as well showed
that you know this method of geotemporal
clustering often misidentifies
transmission and misses transmission
where it actually has occurred which is
really important
so what are some of the types of current
modern outbreak detection whenever we
look at the steps of outbreak detection
these are the steps from the Centers for
Disease Control and prevention here in
the United States
so you have to establish the existence
of an outbreak look at the diagnosis get
a case definition make a hypothesis and
at the end essentially after you've done
all of this number 10 right here compare
and reconcile with laboratory
Environmental Studies that one right
there is often where we use genomic
sequencing or some type of genomic
method to confirm or refute that
presence of that outbreak but after the
outbreak has already been established so
what does this actually look like
there's this paper from CDC folks in
England general medicine that depicts it
very well
without sequencing we have these series
of cases that are unsorted that are
occurring throughout time that may or
may not be linked together but what
sequencing allows us to do is connect
those cases to better guide our
interventions to better guide uh where
we know the outbreak is actually
happening and better direct our
resources
so that's really important to use
but how is genomic sequencing used in
the outbreak settings within hospitals
right now
So within hospitals we have infections
that unfortunately unfortunately are
common throughout the hospital that
occur throughout so each one of these
dots represent an infection that's going
on in the hospital and oftentimes for us
and other infection prevention
departments it takes one astute
clinician a nurse a physician within a
single unit that will say you know I've
had six infections six infections of C
diff on my unit in the past couple of
weeks this is really weird so they'll
often uh call the infection prevention
department
from there the infection prevention
department has to do a really intense
review they have to formulate a line
list make a case definition do chart
review again which isn't too
standardized
um and then and they'll actually start
to do interventions um hand hygiene
education etc etc at the end of that all
outbreak sometimes they might perform
whole genome sequencing again to see
which infections are related and which
ones may not be related to see do we
even have an outbreak in our experience
and I think the experience of many
others very few of these infections end
up being related if any indicating some
type of transmission between these
patients
and then from there we'll often tailor
the intervention to say do we need to
interrupt environmental transmission or
a common source or is this just an
increase of heis from endogenous
organisms and maybe we need to have more
education on that and then they'll keep
monitoring for different infections
so what do we call this we like to call
this reactive whole genome sequencing so
it's whenever you sequence in response
to a suspected outbreak to either
confirm or refute that presence of the
outbreak we like to say this is a
traditional approach on the other hand
the new approaches that we're seeing a
lot is genomic sequencing surveillance
so sequencing regardless of the presence
of an outbreak
some of the questions is you know why
don't we actually sequence everything
why not just sequence everything in the
first place cost operations and
interpretation are all issues um with uh
to think about with that which we'll get
into in a bit
um but one of the things that we wanted
to look into is who's actually using
sequencing surveillance and what did
they find because maybe that will better
guide us on how do we effectively use
this approach
so that's what we wanted to do and we
did a systematic review and published
this a couple years ago
um in a um the antimicrobial stewardship
Healthcare epidemiology Journal
where we essentially wanted to look to
see who is using genomic sequencing
surveillance and one of the other
effects that we want to look into is
Hughes using machine learning or
statistical methods to also detect
outbreaks but for the purposes of this
webinar we're going to stick to the
sequencing surveillance aspects
so we wanted to look at published
reports of Institutions that have done
genomic surveillance so we use these
initial Search terms essentially to say
give us a broad catch of who's actually
using it we had um seven a little over
700 abstracts from there and we had to
filter out a lot of abstracts that were
often Community Based because we wanted
to look at a healthcare surveillance
non-infection related or actually in the
end reactive sequencing
from there we're able to filter it down
a little bit more a lot of them we
weren't able to readily extract the data
um and we added a couple more and in the
end we had about 42 studies across the
time span up to 2021 that did some type
of genomic surveillance within a
healthcare setting so what are these 42
studies find what did they show
combining all these 44 studies or sorry
42 studies there were about 20 percent
of the isolates that were sequenced were
related
but it's important to look at our
methodology on these studies how do we
call relatedness is often based upon
single nucleotide polymorphism
thresholds snip thresholds what we did
find is that this figure over here there
is a wide variability of what snip
threshold was used based upon the study
except for C diff C difficile the sniff
threshold was relatively low but you can
look at staph aureus here over on the
right where some institutions use the 50
snip threshold and some use um way under
10. so there isn't a well agreed upon
standard of what defines relatedness let
alone the pipelines were that were also
used here as well only two of these
studies were done in real time almost
all of these studies had retrospectively
banked isolates that they were able to
go back in to pull from those isolates
and see what they found through
sequencing surveillance
the majority of these almost all only
use geotemporal clustering whenever they
did their analysis they only looked at
where were the patients in the unit and
essentially did they have overlap with
another patient in the same time frame
which was pretty restrictive in our
experience and I'll get into some
examples why that could be restrictive
later
again like I said there was a vast
difference in snip cutoffs used but what
we did find is that the use is
increasing over the many years that we
looked at these studies there was a
increasing a consistent increase the
amount of published studies that were
using genomic surveillance indicating
that the future is probably going to
show that a lot more people are going to
be going to be using this technique so I
wanted to share some notable examples of
some studies that were pulled from the
systematic review this first one from
Sullivan in 2019 looked at MRSA
bloodstream infections that was
originally prompted by a neonatal ICU so
in ICU with children and babies that had
an outbreak and they they took that
outbreak and they went backwards in time
to look at all these MRSA bloodstream
infections prior to that and what they
found was a previously undetected
outbreak within their hospital but in a
separate Tower in an adult unit and on
deeper investigation they found that the
same ventilators parts of these
ventilators that were being used on the
adults during previously undetected
transmission were then transferred over
to the neonatal ICU and potentially seed
at the start of this neonatal ICU
outbreak so the takeaway here is that if
this was done in real time they could
have potentially prevented this NICU
outbreak from occurring in the future
this other one from Roy in 2019 looked
at influenza for about six months um and
they found whenever they did sequencing
surveillance that the infection
prevention department traditionally
using our outbreak detection of looking
at the h and ends and trying to
geotemporal Cluster those often
misidentified outbreaks but also missed
outbreaks in other units this quote here
down on the right was from the paper as
that sequencing was able to uncover
probable kryptogenics Transmission in
one unit while excluding a suspected
breakdown of infection prevention and
another unit so again sequencing
surveillance can guide your
interventions that we're using within a
hospital
and this last study here that I want to
show um folks is from verbal kaban and
2020 where they also looked at
sequencing of MRSA over the course of
two years and the main takeaway that I
got from this paper is that there was
vast MRSA transmission
um that went undetected but it spanned
the entire study period uh so they found
16 patients over 21 months in nine
different units so when we think of our
traditional I uh detection of
geotemporal clustering of patients have
to be in the same unit within the short
time frame this completely gets rid of
that is that we have patients that are
spread out across time on multiple
different units that have suspected
transmission that's actually going on
yeah so why don't we adopt sequencing
surveillance like we just showed there's
a lot of studies showing its value and
detecting these unrecognized outbreaks
they can guide our interventions to
better direct and make sure that our
interventions are going to be accurate
but what are barriers is there a cost
benefit to doing this sequencing isn't
free so will we actually be able to save
money by doing this and how does this
actually add up to the traditional
infection prevention that we currently
do in hospitals so this is what we
wanted to start study in our research
group at the University of Pittsburgh
and this is why we wanted to create this
tool called the enhanced detection
system for healthcare Associated
transmission or Ed's hat
what Ed's hat is is essentially it
combines two things we combine bacterial
whole genome sequencing surveillance
where this helps us detect the outbreak
early and we also wanted to use um the
EHR data because it's so readily
available and and it would be time
consuming to review all these charts so
by automating this process this assists
Us in helping find the transmission
Route that might be causing the
transmission and the outbreak that we
detect early and ideally this system
together would detect our outbreak early
prevent infections and deaths and save
the hospital costs in the end
so what does this look like in practice
potentially and the current state of Ip
you have an outbreak that takes a while
to be detected oftentimes we need a lot
of cases to detect this outbreak in the
traditional infection prevention methods
but with Ed's hat ideally because of the
sequencing surveillance we would detect
the outbreak at the second patient and
we would be hopefully be able to find
what's causing that outbreak intervene
and prevent any further infections from
actually happening which is where the
cost savings come into play
so what does this look like in practice
we have patients in our hospital all
patients have EHR data and that EHR data
exists as charge codes patients are
charged for their medications their
procedures their bed location the
providers that see them that is routine
what's also routine is clinical
specimens that are sent to our lab
whenever our clinician suspects they
might have an infection they culture the
blood the sputum the wound any part of
that culture is sent to our lab so the
only new thing that we're doing here
with our research group is that we
collect those isolates and we perform
sequencing surveillance on them we
combine that with the EHR data and
essentially do a large case control
study to say where are our outbreak
patients and where are everybody else in
the hospital and what's common in terms
of the exposures among our outbreak
patients and could that possibly be a
signal that's causing the outbreak to
help us identify that outbreak identify
that transmission out and make an
intervention and stop the outbreak from
occurring
so we wanted to publish this
um to see what could be a potential
effect of this be and we showed this a
couple years ago in the journal of
clinical infectious diseases the impact
of what sequencing surveillance and
machine learning of Ed's hat could have
for infection prevention departments
so the methods behind this though we use
that we sequence
um bacterial pathogens for clinical
cultures for about two years between
2016 and 2018 prior to covid and we
wanted those isolates that had potential
Healthcare Associated infection
um impact so we wanted the clinical
isolates where patients have been in the
hospital for three or more days or they
had some prior inpatient outpatient
exposure within our hospital system in
the prior 30 days uh this was mainly
because we've had experience in the past
with patients who all have outpatient
procedures such as ercp scope procedures
we'll get these um
exposures in the outpatient setting
become septic and then present to our
Hospital ill but the transmission
actually came from that outpatient
exposure or their prior discharge so by
using this inclusion criteria we were
able to better capture these infections
and we selected these species to look
into these were high impact High
morbidity mortality common infections
that we see in our hospital that were
able to readily gather and this was also
NIH funded so we were a bit Limited in
the amounts of species that we could
actually select uh you can note there
that we looked at MRSA but one of the
things would be really valuable to look
into would be mssa as well
so how did this go um in terms of the
methodology to Analyze This
we use the machine learning algorithm
essentially with like I said a case
control methodology to evaluate our
outbreaks where our cases as everyone
defined by sequencing and our controls
as everybody else in the hospital in the
prior 30 days and this figure to the
right essentially shows the workflow we
have a patient with a clinical culture
that meets our inclusion criteria for
sequencing and we sequence it and to see
do we detect an outbreak and we
identified that essentially by 15 Snips
or lower for all organisms except for C
diff which we use the two-step threshold
so if we have two or more patients we
look into the outbreak and we see if the
machine learning algorithm detects the
transmission Route if not I would still
review the outbreak if it did I would
review that route and see you know is
this biologically plausible for actually
causing transmission and then we would
judicate all these transmission mounts
and what we also wanted to add in here
too is model a potential clinical
economic impact saying if we were to run
this in real time where would we have
intervened and based upon some
conservative and loose estimates of
interventions how many infections could
we have prevented ideally
so what did we find in these two years
we sequenced um 3 100 isolates uh that
map to about 2 700 unique patients by
organism and almost 300 of those
isolates about 10.8 percent of what we
sequence were related and 99 different
clusters
you can see there's a wide variability
in the percent related so if you look at
VRE ephesium we sequence a good bit and
35 percent of those Isis related but
whereas if you look at pseudomonas
originosa we sequence a lot of those but
in the end only about four percent of
those are related so there was a big
difference in terms of percent
relatedness indicating potential
transmission within this as well we also
look at attributable readmissions
because of these um related infections
and found that there were a good bit of
seven day and 30-day readmissions that
were due to these potentially
transmitted infections that were
genetically related
so this next figure here
um which is a figure that I really like
that was created by one of our folks in
our lab
um shows the depicts the outbreaks that
we detected so each dot here represents
an isolate that we've sequence which is
color-coded and labeled
um by the different species and this
Inner Circle you see here are all the
outbreaks that were interconnected
um and the outer ring here shows the
unrelated uh or isolates that we
detected so like I mentioned before you
can see VRE here in the top in the dark
blue we sequenced a good bit and the
majority of them uh 35 or so percent
were related whereas
pseudomonasurugenosa not too many of
them are related but there's still some
significantly larger outbreaks here as
well
so what were some
what were some notable outbreaks here
there were a few um the first two I'll
talk a bit more detail in just a minute
the third one here we had outbreaks of
multiple pathogens at this chronic care
facility that was a third party chronic
Care Facility but it was embedded within
our um our Hospital walls we also had
outbreaks of multiple different
pathogens on one of our Intensive Care
Unit we had on these outbreaks of C C
diff associated with wound care which
was very interesting so wound care in
our hospital is a consult service of
nurses who have a centralized location
who would then spread out all all
throughout our hospital and see patients
with different type of decubitus ulcers
non-healing wounds and then inspect
these patients so plausibility wise it
was possible and that's why we saw a lot
of different C diff infections in
different units spread out across time
and this last example here um shows how
specific Ed's hat can get with
infections or two MRSA infections
associated with EEG where uh two
patients on the um on the same day were
seen by a physician and an EEG Tech
um and then subsequently uh on two
separate units developed genomically
related MRSA infections and had no other
commonalities other than this initial
console which was really leading but I
want to talk about two of these
outbreaks um which were really important
to us and we described in more detail
this first one here uh we published
separately in clinical infectious
diseases a few years ago which was an
outbreak of VRE ethecium that we traced
back to Interventional Radiology
and what we did um in this time frame
with Ed's hat is that we would analyze
some outbreaks with a 6 to 12 month lag
because we didn't want to interfere with
our infection prevention department
because we wanted to compare what's the
impact of Ed's hat versus traditional IP
but at our six-month evaluation
initially we found
um this outbreak of theory of 10 patient
isolates and what does um figure here on
the right shows is a pairwise snip heat
map of all the isolates that we get to
analyze at that time so essentially this
this red box right here shows a very low
snip threshold under 15 Snips of 10
potentially genetically related isolates
so we wanted to take a deeper dive of
what was going on with these 10 VRE
infections
when we looked at commonalities of these
VRE infections it was important to note
that essentially all of these patients
were spread out across different units
and these infections occurred through
many months because we were doing an
initial evaluation after six months so
you can see here
um the the culture day was spread out
over 260 days from when we first started
sequencing and a lot of these infections
of ere were pretty invasive blood
different abdominal specimens as well
the only thing common that was among all
these patients is that within 22 days of
their culture date all but one of them
had an Interventional Radiology
procedure and furthermore all all those
Interventional Radiology procedures had
to deal with contrast injections and you
can see here on the far right that many
of these infections were also
polymicrobial
so I was working as an infection
preventionist at the time so we said we
decided to perform an outbreak
investigation and this is the our
Interventional Radiology Suite that we
had
and you can see um when you walk in this
is where the patient lays um on the
table here on the right a little bit is
the contrast injector where there's an
IR technician that will work the machine
there The Physician will stand next to
the patient with a sterile field that's
established next to the position as well
often with another tech who will handle
the sterile field as well so we asked
the the IR Suite to say okay prepare a
contrast injector as if the patient is
coming in
and what this contrast injector looks
like
um is shown on this slide here where you
have this sterile packaging of this
injector here and you can imagine if
you're reaching into this package with
an ungloved hand or even non-sterile
glove tan that you might touch portions
of this device that looks like a straw
which is called a quick field tube and
what this does is then this is inserted
into the pressure jacket of this
injector and as we watched our
technician perform this they did not
have gloves on they did unfortunately
not perform hand hygiene before this so
they touch portions of this straw
and what this actually looks like um and
this is from the manufacturer training
contrast and essentially move the bottle
of contrast up and down while the
injector then starts to suck up some of
this contrast and loads it into the
machine so you can imagine if you have
touched portions of this straw right
here the contrast is also going to touch
portions of that straw and that contrast
is what is then direct injected directly
into patients next
so what we found is that all but one of
these IR procedures for these sequence
isolates were performed by the same
group of ir staff and there was one IR
Tech that was scheduled to work on all
procedure dates of these sequence cases
and this IR Tech was assigned to a
position where they essentially assist
with a lot of these cases
excuse me so a lot of our interventions
dealt with
um increasing uh the uh disinfection
within the IR Suite increasing
um
increasing the cleanliness and also
improving the practice to be more
sterile in terms of the loading of the
contrast injectors as well and since we
have made these interventions we have
not detected any more Interventional
Radiology
Associated cases within this outbreak
this other outbreak that I mentioned
before um is the outbreak of pseudomonas
originosa that we Trace back to a
contaminated gastroscope as well so part
of infection prevention practices may be
to culture routinely Scopes endoscopes
that are used on patients and for those
who may not be familiar endoscopes are
scopes that are used to look down
patients esophageal area into their
intestinal area or down into their lungs
essentially to examine take cultures
take biopsies and these Scopes in the
past have been implicated in many
outbreaks ercp Scopes especially and
that's because these Scopes cannot
effectively be sterilized and there are
portions of these Scopes that can often
become contaminated so one of the
suggested practices is to buy a quality
improvement measure essentially is
culture your scope to see are your
disinfection measures adequately
appropriately in actually preventing
contamination and possible infections in
your patients and that's what our
Hospital would do we would often
routinely culture our Scopes
occasionally to see do we recover
anything and if we did recover something
because of Ed's hat we would actually
culture those isolates as well
so what did we find within this outbreak
we had six um patients that had
genetically related uh pseudonymous
regionalsa with very few Snips among all
of them
um they were spread out off of different
units and spread out over 200 days
across again so your geotemporal
clustering isn't really holding true
here these patients were spread out
across time and space what we found
among the first first four patients is
that they all had gastroscopy
um by this one gastroscope a that was
used on these patients so the same
gastroscope was used on subsequent pay
on four different patients this fourth
patient here right here subsequently
after their infection had gastroscopy
with gastroscope B which in that
gastroscope b was then used on patient
five this patient 6 here definitively
did not have any gastroscopy formerly
noted in their chart whenever we looked
at this patient's chart they actually
did have a bedside gastroscopy which is
very rare in our Institution and we were
unable to retrieve a serial number for
that gastroscope so we weren't able to
definitively say which gastroscope did
this six patient have although it's
likely that that patient did have one of
these gastroscopes as well
and what we found at the end
um so
at the end whenever we did some routine
sequencing of our scope isolates is that
we had a scope isolate that was positive
for pseudomonas originosa
um a few day days after this last
patient patient number six and whenever
we sequenced that it was actually
related to this outbreak and that
gastroscope was gastroscope a so it was
in a sense our Smoking Gun within this
outbreak and it's important to note that
at the time uh with our traditional
infection prevention that positive
gastroscope was not these prior patients
because of that geotemporal clustering
so much as elapsed that time frame that
that gastroscope was not linked to these
other prior patients so we did some
initial economic modeling and
hypothesized if we did real-time
sequencing and we pulled that
gastroscope at patient number two we
could have potentially saved patient
three four and five from actually having
their infections probably patient six
but again we couldn't actually confirm
that gastroscopy did occur and there was
high potential cost savings with here um
because the cost of treating infections
is very high based upon the cost of
doing sequencing surveillance we have
some preliminary cost Savings of over
fifty thousand dollars save and this
outbreak if we did real-time sequencing
by preventing the treatment of these
infections
so going back to our overall two-year
analysis like I said before we wanted to
compare what did Ed's hat find versus
what did traditional infection
prevention time during that same
two-year time frame we got 15 requests
for what infection prevention thought
were potential outbreaks that were
occurring for about 133 patients and
it's important to note that only five of
those 133 patients so about three
percent of those patients were
genetically related from two clusters
meaning that we vastly misidentify
outbreaks where we think they're
occurring and what EDS hat showed of our
high percent relatedness is that we miss
outbreaks when they're actually
occurring as well this is where we go
back to that initial quote that we
misidentify outbreaks and we miss
outbreaks when they do occur because of
geotemporal clustering and this is where
sequencing surveillance can really add
to eviction prevention department
so what did our economic modeling show
again we modeled you know if we were
running ads hat in real time and we
intervene with some um
hypothesize interventions with certain
levels of efficacy that were Guided by
literature-based Effectiveness what
could we have prevented
um in a uh in a scenario we could have
prevented 25 to 63 Transmissions if we
were running this in real time based off
of some conservative and more loose um
uh parameters but overall we could have
saved upwards of almost seven hundred
thousand dollars in this two-year study
period because of the cost of sequencing
again is low relative to the the high
cost of treating these infections and
using a probabilistic sensitivity
analysis of running different models we
show that edsat was cost Savings in a
large portion of our simulations that we
were around regardless of the um
conservative or loose parameters that we
use which is shown in this figure here
where this there's this cost savings
region where if we're actually doing
sequencing surveillance we would have
been cost savings and a lot of these
simulations that we actually ran
so what can we conclude from here
sequencing surveillance of bacterial
pathogens and this machine learning of
EHR has really high promise in improving
our personal infection
methods for detecting and investigating
our outbreaks we have really good proof
that cost benefit analysis shows that we
can say potentially save money even
though the C cost of sequencing is high
so our questions here remain is how do
we actually adopt this technology for
real-time use and more so will it
actually be effective and how do we
actually prove that it's difficult
because when we look at this
retrospective analysis again we we
compared it to the traditional infection
prevention analysis that occurred at
that time frame and we hypothesized when
we modeled what what would we have done
but how do we actually say you know
would that have actually happened if we
did that in in real time it's trying to
prove the counterfactual of an
intervention which is very difficult to
prove and I'll get to some of those
examples here um with some of our
real-time data so we took this um out
analysis of our two-year EDS hat and did
a lot of analysis essentially said you
know we why why are we waiting let's
just start doing sequencing surveillance
there are some barriers into
implementing our machine learning
aspects that we're still working on
today but we had some good control to
actually start doing sequencing
surveillance within our hospital and
that's what we decided to start doing
so what does this actually look like
within our hospital system again like I
said you have your patient who's
hospitalized within an inpatient setting
or had some recent Healthcare exposure
as well
in a clinician often a position will
suspect that they have this infection
order that culture that blood that
sputum skin anything and send it down to
our Clinical Laboratory building
which is located right next to our
hospital so that culture ends up being
positive and then twice a week in a
real-time setting our lab we call it my
gel macromial genomic and epidemiology
laboratory well query culture results as
they result every uh twice a week to see
which new cultures each week will meet
our inclusion criteria so have they had
that recent Healthcare exposure or have
they been in the hospital for
um greater than three or more days and
one of our laboratory technicians will
also twice a week go down to our
Clinical Laboratory building
collect these isolates and bring them
back up to our laboratory and we sent
them out to be sequencing through some
of our collaborators internally and
externally to have that sequencing
performed
we get that sequencing data back
relatively quickly and we analyze that
again for relating this to other
isolates and in this real time phase
we're still using that threshold of 15
snip cut off for all isolates except for
C diff where we use a two-step threshold
as well
and then I initially
um myself uh if we find an outbreak I
will perform an initial cluster
investigation by reviewing patient
charts seeing what's common among these
patients um that could potentially be
causing this outbreak and will notify
our infection prevention Partners within
our hospital to say that we have a new
outbreak here are the patients here's
the preliminary results of what we think
is actually causing this outbreak and
from there they will also analyze
themselves to reaffirm what I found and
then perform any necessary interventions
in a real-time fashion that could um
stop the transmission where we think the
Transmissions actually happening
so what have we found
so we started sequencing in real time
for these surveillance of pathogens back
in November of 2021 and as of January
2023 we've sequenced a little over 2500
isolates and about nine percent of them
are related 237
um isolates involved in 84 different
outbreaks ranging anywhere between two
patients up to 13 patients and what's
interesting is that we're detecting
about one new outbreak or one new
patient essentially every single week
during this time frame and a lot of
these um outbreaks that we see that are
getting larger these larger ones are
very uh make a mess and resistant
ephesium outbreaks
and some of our preliminary data show
that we'll be publishing soon as well is
that these VRE outbreaks we think are
driven a lot by rectal Carriage where we
see a lot of
um related rectal Carriage isolates that
have then occasionally you see these
clinical isolates um so we all have some
data on that as well but some notable
outbreaks that we've found so far
um we have this outbreak of pseudomonas
infections associated with a single
bronchoscope
um other a lot of other endoscope
outbreaks that are detected at two
patients and what's important from this
is that we're detecting these outbreaks
of endoscopes at two patients and then
just removing the scope from service and
then we don't see any further uh
transmission related to those scope
outbreaks this one scope outbreak we
found actually dealt with four patients
of two different species and whenever we
removed the scope which was in a month
time frame they actually found that it
failed a leak test which is a quality
test to see how well does just
um scope get clean and if it fails this
leak test it might be leaking some
fluids which is an indicator that it
could be contaminated or have some
issues um being clean as well
we've also seen multiple unit-based
clusters with different pathogens
similar to what are some of our findings
in the past where
this other outbreak here um that will
also be publishing separately
it was a pseudo outbreak
of 14 patients all with serratia
pleboxytoka or pseudomonas from autopsy
cultures so it was very interesting we
found initial three patients early on
with serratio marcessins from autopsy
blood cultures and whenever we did an
investigation of these patients we found
that these patients had died at outside
hospitals at outside UPMC hospitals
separate from our initial hospital then
they were brought in centrally to our
hospital for their autopsy and had blood
cultures that were drawn that had
genetically identical serration
marcessins so when you think of this
epidemiologically there isn't any epic
commonalities among these patients when
while they were alive at these separate
hospitals because nothing was shared
among those patients but what they do
have in common was their autopsy that
was performed
and again we had subsequent other
patients with cleboxy Toca and
pseudomonas so we performed
um a observation investigation including
cultures of the autopsy Suite
um and what that actually looks like
with an autopsy is unlike whenever
patients are alive and you can get
peripheral sticks you actually have to
open up the chest of the patient and get
the blood from the vena cava of the
heart because blood is not readily
flowing and what we saw initially before
a patient is brought onto the autopsy
table is that they would wash down this
table
um with water from a tap sink and then
essentially it's a non-sterile procedure
where they would then try to disinfect
the area of the vena cava and insert a
needle into that blood area and pull
that out we found that that area wasn't
properly being disinfected and whenever
we did some environmental cultures
because a lot of these bugs are water
related bugs we took cultures of the
sink of the tube of the drain and this
first picture he here picture number a
um from the the faucet that was it was
taken from we had genetically identical
pseudomous eruginosa matching that of an
autopsy blood culture from another
patient that was overgrown likely
overgrowing serration other drugs on
there as well which was again our
Smoking Gun that we found potential
environmental contamination that was
Guided by genomic surveillance and
allowed us to have better intervention
so that we could have you know
confidence in our autopsy cultures were
actually true and not contaminated like
we found here so this is one of the
examples where we can use sequencing
surveillance to guide environmental and
IP interventions to have quality
improvement initiatives
so what's our summary here that we can
conclude
real-time sequencing is possible now we
have quick turnaround time within our
Hospital which is really key here as
well we can detect outbreaks at two
patients and that turnaround time is
really key from our preliminary data we
see about 14 days go by on median from
when we have that patient culture date
at the bedside to whenever we have the
genomic sequencing results and we can
make an intervention about two weeks and
that time is really important that we
decrease that time because during that
time frame we have essentially ongoing
transmission that could be happening as
well but real-time sequencing is
possible now with this technology
and because of that sequencing we can
direct our infection prevention
interventions and we can make them
quickly we can pull those endoscopes we
can guide our interventions to direct to
say hey we think we have suspected a
transmission going here now here's our
evidence let's direct our infection
prevention initiatives here and
currently what we're doing now um is
we're analyzing the effectiveness of our
interventions actually preventing
transmission like I mentioned before
it's really hard to prove this
counterfactual because in our two-year
retrospective paper we we hypothesized
what we could have prevented and now
currently we're saying you know this is
what we're doing in intervening in real
time but how do we actually effectively
approve that prove that counter factual
data
um and it's hard to compare with some of
our data because in our current
real-time scenario we're in a postcode
during a coveted era where we know hais
are more common and we've seen increase
of transmission and if we wanted to
compare it to our or prior to your data
that was pre-coded so we have some
confounding going on that we're working
through but coming up here at the Shea
conference which is a healthcare
epidemiology conference in 2023
um here in April I'll actually be
presenting some of the our analysis on
the effectiveness and our preliminary
findings about how effective is our
real-time surveillance at preventing
transmission and I'm really excited to
share that data at Shea so if you're
going to Shay I would love if you
attended the session there and we could
talk there as well
so again we I want to talk about some of
these barriers to implementation that I
mentioned at the end at the beginning
um again why don't we just sequence
everything we see that from these slides
and our data that sequencing
surveillance is possible you can guide
IP interventions and it looks relatively
successful at preventing transmission
again cost uh cost is always a barrier
but again we've had an analysis that
shows that you could potentially save
costs at uh because the cost of
sequencing is so low and the cost of
treating these affections is so high
that if you just prevent a few of these
affections it pays for itself
um and just last week there was a great
systematic review that was just
published uh just last week in microbial
genomics it was a systematic review of
um cost effectiveness of whole genome
sequencing surveillance of bacterial
pathogens that shows a lot of promise
that that our findings were not just a
one-off that other folks have found that
sequencing surveillance can be very cost
effective within the hospital sending as
well so it's you we have to convince um
Healthcare leadership that you know by
adopting this technology it is a
cost-saving um long-run investment that
we can actually use
infrastructure it's important that we
have infrastructure the machines the
materials the actual workspace that we
can properly sequence and interpret the
in bioinformatics so there's a lot of
folks out there that you can actually
Outsource your bioinformatics
capabilities if you don't actually have
that in-house and that's oftentimes some
things that we'll do internally if we
have a lot of samples we'll work with um
external Partners to send out our
sequencing and they those Partners as
well often have fast turnaround times
and they're competing to really lower
that turnaround time and that cost to
try to to try to do more sequencing so
that's always an option if you don't
have that infrastructure already within
your own Institution
education it's a very important that you
know we have this technology but can we
appropriately use it as they say in a
clinical setting you never want to order
a test if you don't know what you're
going to do with that test in the end
the same thing is true with sequencing
surveillance you never want to do
sequencing surveillance in real time if
you don't know what to actually do with
it so it's really important that we
train our infection prevention staff and
our hospital epidemiologists about
actually how to use this data and what
is the best way to actually report it to
the infection prevention staff and from
our experience like we just showed they
you know they don't really want to know
the very detailed bioinformatic outputs
the coverage how well how well did we
sequence it what were the what were the
methods of sequencing what the end user
the IP really just wants to know and the
clinicians that we go talk to is who are
our outbreak patients and can we find
suspected transmission routes between
these patients that's what they want to
know at the end user and actually how we
um
teach our IPS to appropriately
understand that so then they can then go
to our clinicians our bedside staff to
properly display and convey this is the
this is the results we have and how do
we actually make action about that um
with this data
and lastly support we have to have
leadership from all levels of Hospital
Administration to have this type
initiative within our Hospital uh it's
it's hard to convince a hospital to say
look let's use this new technology
that's going to have a lot of upfront
costs to uncover a lot of new outbreaks
we've never known about we're very lucky
at UPMC that we have very supportive
leadership that wants to adopt this
technology because we know the power
that this technology can uncover we can
uncover outbreaks so that otherwise
undetected that other institutions are
not doing so we predict in the future
this might be the new standard and we're
trying to early adopt this to show that
we're very supportive in doing this and
having quality improvement and improving
the care of our patients to make patient
care more safer and that's the message
that we give to our leadership and our
leadership gives to all of our staff to
have the support to have this type of
Technology within our hospital so I
think these barriers are very important
barriers there's a lot to work out with
these barriers as well
um but there there are steps to actually
overcome these barriers and these are
things that I would blindly talk about
with folks as well at the shade
conference here or any questions that we
might have about this webinar as well
because these are important factors that
we're still battling to overcome both
within our own system as well and as we
share it with other Hospital
institutions
so I want to thank everybody
um and thank the folks that organized
this webinar um I'd be happy to take any
questions again here within the chat
um but my email my contact info is are
there as well I'm pretty active on
Twitter so please feel free to reach out
if you don't reach out right here and I
would be happy to chat with you and
again happy to take any questions thank
you
thank you Dr Sunderman for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
so let's get started we've got some
great questions coming in from our
audience
and our first question here asks once
you've determined outbreak in real time
what is the steps for resolution do you
use wgs to follow up after intervention
thanks Haley that's a really quick great
question a lot of the steps we were
extremely close with our IP Department
like I said so we do that initial chart
review to give some inclination of what
we think might be causing the outbreak
from there they then go perform detailed
Epi investigation doing Audits and the
interviews and it's very specific to the
type of signal that we might be seeing
but a lot of that
um might stem from do we need to do
environmental cultures or do we need to
do additional patient surveillance is
that an actual indication of what we're
seeing and if that's the case we'll
we'll collect those samples and perform
sequencing them on them as well to see
if it matches our
our strain of concern but additionally
what's nice about the surveillance
aspect is regardless of the outbreak or
the presence or what we think is the
resolution of the outbreak we keep on
performing surveillance on all the
future isolates as well so it kind of
acts as like a Qi measure to how
effective we're on our interventions did
did it prevent future cases from showing
up or are we still seeing cases in the
future and I think that's one of the
strengths that sequencing surveillance
can can give to you
great thank you next question here very
informative and compelling presentation
Dr Sunderman what sequencing depth
x-fold coverage is typically required
for achieving the desired resolution 15
SNP threshold
that's a great question
um bioinformatics
outcomes are important to note I'm not a
buying permission slide trip by training
so I don't have those um details off of
the top of my head but I'll be glad to
follow up
um in an email about the coverage and
depth and all the other types of reads
for the type of QA that we use but we do
have internal pipelines that we use at
Pitt that we've developed that has some
pretty strict uh QA measures that we go
by
e
Dr Sunderman in a two-year time if saved
excuse me 692
000 how much would it cost to do
surveillance in that time by wgs if each
run costs one thousand dollars how many
runs would need to be done every month
or year
so I think it's important that when we
look at the context of sequencing
surveillance we see that there's been a
large decrease in the Raw cost of
sequencing for pathogens in the past
many years what we see internally and
with one of our partners
um and what we based upon on our model
within our publication is that our cost
of sequencing are estimated about 70 or
80 dollars per isolate which translates
to different for the amount of runs that
you do but that is a very important
question of what what is the threshold
uh that Healthcare facilities may need
to sequence to see some cost savings
benefit
um and that is something that we're
trying to work on modeling with some of
our other hospitals to look at how what
are the types of infections that
hospitals are seeing based upon the
Acuity of care and the patient
demographics that they see and how much
would they actually need to sequence and
an estimation to say you know this would
be less beneficial because it might not
be cost beneficial for a very small
Hospital in a rural setting that doesn't
see a lot of these complex patients
versus you know acute care facility that
sees hundreds of these patients every
single month so it's a it's an important
detail to work out and it's something
that I hope that we can see addressed in
the near future
great next question here asks did you
say it takes 14 days from sample
collection to having an assembled genome
how much of that is sample processing
versus analysis
right so um it's about a median
turnaround time for 14 days from the
time at the bedside where the clinician
takes the sample from a patient so they
take a blood draw take a womb swab or
anything from that time point on to
whenever we actually have our sequencing
analysis to looking to see if we have a
new outbreak we see about 14 days and a
lot of this is because we are a research
setting currently and we are required
twice a week to go down and walk to
another building to actually gather that
isil bring it back to our lab prep it
send it out or sequence it internally so
I think a lot of the time in reduction
and on our front could be in increasing
the frequency in which we sequence our
turnaround time for the actual
sequencing is just about you know a day
or an overnight and we're lucky to have
some great bioinformaticians internally
where the pipeline for analysis is
completely automated and we see a very
rapid turnaround time to whenever we can
actually compare it to our prior
isolates so I think for it's very
dependent on your setting about where
you can actually reduce your turnaround
times are you a research setting or are
you sending it out are you doing it
internally
right
next question here how feasible is wgs
for organizations without that
capability on site
so without that on site I think it
depends on
you want to partner with an uh an
industry group there are lots of
Industry companies out there that offer
raw sequencing where you can provide
samples and they give you the sequencing
data to you know the full end of you
that you provide the sample they do the
sequencing and they provide you with
analyzes on the output of what potential
outbreaks that you might be seeing so I
think it's it's dependent on do you want
to invest that internally in some
upfront costs and have that training and
onboarding and those creation of
pipelines or how much of that do you
actually want to Outsource to
third-party companies
um and comparing those different types
of services
great next question does this 70 to 80
dollar isolate include labor costs
overheads Etc
um it does not directly include that
cost as well
um but that is something uh in an
upcoming paper we're going to be looking
at the the cost of you know having those
ftes in place to actually establish that
as well if you want to actually have
that run internally
great now what is a typical batch size
for a sequencing run
um that's something I'm not sure off the
top of my head
uh I I can't confidently say that off
the top of my head but I can follow up
if you email me
all right no problem
all right next question this is a
two-part question here and this one asks
or first dates this was a fantastic talk
um what bioinformatics pipeline are you
using for this and the second part to
this question is your system able to
identify plasmids transposos shared
across different species and if so what
have you learned about pitfalls in
genomic surveillance methods of
comparing carbo PanAm masses or other
plasma Trends both in related
Transmission in different species
well thank you so much for the the
comment
um within the pipeline it's something
that one of our expert bioinformaticians
has created internally
um and using different types of methods
that we validated throughout but in
terms of plasmids and transposons that's
actually something that we're very
interested within our lab and one of our
collaborators
um Dr Daria Van Tyne who does a lot of
work in this and we've actually
published uh a lot of preliminary data
and a really great upcoming paper as
well on plasma transfer and transmission
within Healthcare settings and we're
able to show using some different
methods than what we traditionally do
that we actually see a lot of
transmission of plasmids with drug
resistance happening in our hospital
that isn't actually detected through
tradition what we think of traditional
sequencing methods but that's something
that we're exploring of what is the
value of adding that into our routine
Pipeline and is it something that you
know we can act upon to reduce the
spread of AMR but thank you for that
question
great all right we have time for a few
more questions here this next one asks
do you use any patient metadata or
epidemiological information as input for
the analysis or is that only used post
hoc
so uh in a way so that's a great
question in a way for whenever we do
Islip collection we look at how long
they were in the hospital if they had
recent Healthcare exposure but that's
the only type of pre-screening um
inclusion criteria that we do for the
patient
um everything else comes after we detect
the outbreak where we look at these
patient demographics both within the
outbreak and then retrospectively in our
prior publication that's something that
we look at as well for all the control
patients within the hospital but within
a real-time setting we just look at what
an outbreak
all right we have time for one more
question here so we'll wrap up after
this one and this final question asks
when you state you remove the endoscope
from service do you mean it is discarded
or does it go through some additional
enhanced reprocessing process and then
later return to service
oh that's a great clarification to make
so um we we remove it from Service uh
and then we look to see using maybe a
boroscope or doing an additional test
are there any defects with it are those
defects repairable
um and we work with the industry partner
of whoever made the scope
um to see if they can fix those and
address them uh return it disinfect it
again we do another culture before it
even makes it back into service if we're
able to fix it and then once we do
another disinfection it comes back into
Service as well if we're not able to
address the defect and it keeps failing
um it would be discarded as well but
thank you for that question
great all right well thank you again Dr
Sunderman for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor optgen
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone goodbye